sur les douze communes que compte
saint-quentin-en-yvelines cinq maires
ont été élus dès le premier tour
c'est didier fischer à coignières qui
fait le plus gros score de ce scrutin
il est élu avec 76 71 % des voix face à
exalter girard on a une participation
qui est relativement faible
je pense qu'elle est au dessus quand
même de la participation nationale ce
qui prouve que quand même sur coignières
on s'est mobilisé avec un écart de plus
de 3 points d'un bureau à l'autre
gros score aussi pour bertrand au lion
le maire divers gauche de magny les
hameaux remporte un peu plus de 68 % des
suffrages pour son troisième mandat
on a fait le travail avec nos équipes
d'abord avec l'équipe municipale avec un
partage de bilan avec ensuite un
collectif qui s'est organisée au fur et
à mesure des mois en fin d'année 2010
9,1 collectif ouvert en dehors des
partis avec un certain nombre de valeurs
qui ont fondé notre ne travaillent en
commun à montigny le bretonneux pour sa
première candidature lors à un merckaert
était face à deux listes à l'issue de ce
premier tour et l'emportent avec 62 70 %
des voix je suis très heureux ce soir
évidemment que la liste que j'ai
présentées montrent signé ensemble est
le programme que nous allons proposer
aux habitants rencontre un tel succès
auprès de auprès de la population et
nîmes antenne c'est une vraie
satisfaction évidemment pour nous ce
soir
comment 2014 jean michel fourgous est
élu dès le premier tour à et long cours
avec malgré tout un score un peu moins
important 56 93 % contre 60 % il ya six
ans pour ce scrutin en 2020 de liste
était face à lui bien entendu on est
toujours très heureux d'avoir la
confiance de ses administrés surtout
quand on les connaît quand l'option
d'année on est fiers avec mon équipe
bien sûr d'avoir cette confiance
renouvelée
enfin cinquième maire à saint quentin en
yvelines avoir été élu dès le premier
tour grégory gare et astier le maire
sortant de maurepas l'emporta avec 51,13
% dévouera un score historique puisque
jusqu'à présent aucun maire dans cette
commune avait été élu dès le premier
tour
évidemment une grande fierté c'est la
récompense du travail accompli depuis
six ans maintenant avec mon équipe
le travail de terrain paye énormément
la confiance des électeurs en leur mère
évidemment la récompense aussi du fait
que en a mené une campagne positive et
constructive